[Music]
hello and welcome I'm blessings wi I
will be your host throughout the series
a wolf in sheep's clothing this series
brings the new age and its perilous
practices to the Forefront of discussion
today's guest is a man who describes
himself as a former secular Jew and
cabala occult practitioner today olle
litvac stands Victorious over the occult
he's here to share his testimony from
the new age to a new life in Jesus
welcome brother o it's so nice to have
you here thank you blessings glad to be
here well let's get started I want to
know more about your Jewish background
and how that developed your spirituality
sure um I was actually uh born in
Ukraine in the former Soviet Union and
my family and I while we were
technically Jewish we were only so uh
ethnically and we were allowed to leave
to come to the US
because uh at that time there was a
program that existed to allow Soviet
Jews to leave to go to Israel we worked
it out so that instead of going to
Israel we came to the US and just a
little bit of background most uh Soviet
Jews as well as any other uh group from
any other Faith were uh part of that
group by name only right they they
didn't really uh ascribe to it in any
way because because at that time uh the
Soviet Union was a communist country and
there was no faith of any kind and in
fact you were discouraged from
practicing your faith often times by
threat and so when we came to the us we
didn't really have much of a faith but
because our sponsoring
group were Jewish they volen told me to
go to a Jewish school which is called a
Yeshiva
and uh the Yeshiva is run um like a
regular school you know you have your
math your uh reading and all of the
other regular subjects but then in
addition that to that there's religious
instruction and the religious
instruction um it is of the kind that um
some would describe as at least in my
case legalistic
meaning you were taught okay if you do
these things these these are good works
they're added to your credit right and
they outweigh hopefully the bad things
you've
done and so you never quite knew where
you stood with God because do I have
enough to outweigh the bad things or do
I need to do more good things and often
times those good things came not
necessarily in the way of what we would
describe as good works like feeding the
poor but it would be more like saying
wrote prayers or uh following certain
rituals that and often times these
prayers or rituals you didn't know what
they meant you didn't even you know I
didn't know Hebrew but we were taught to
pray these things in
Hebrew and so it left me with a bad
taste in my mouth in addition because
when I came home from school um my
parents were totally secular so I'd go
from school where they were teaching us
all these things and come home and have
my my uh Kil basa sandwich right and uh
you know Sabbath consisted of Saturday
morning cartoons mhm and there was a lot
of dissonance there right and the the
dissonance eventually made me question
you know what am I really doing in the
school I don't really believe in any of
it my parents don't either why should I
keep going there and at this time we
were already we had moved uh from where
we originally moved to which was Rhode
Island to New York
City and uh I decided to go to public
school and uh so I left
my um my Jewish school and went to
public
school and it was in that public school
system that I got exposed to a whole
different way of life which why which I
was shielded from but that was
the my journey in Judaism and it pretty
much ended there so tell me after you
went from see having such an extreme
Jewish experience to now a public school
setting what was say the limbo in your
spirituality at this particular Junction
in your life yeah it's a great question
uh at this at this point um I really
didn't want to have any kind of religion
in my life at first and I was very happy
to get away from that but what I noticed
of course was that in place of that
there were all these other things that
were happening around me because and I'm
not saying all public schools are like
this but at least the public schools I
went to the kids there many of them came
from broken homes I see and so they
brought you know the the violence the
the sex the um the drugs and all of that
into the school and um I was really out
of my element there and I didn't know
what to do with it all so I kind of
withdrew to myself there were a few
other kids who were kind of in my boat
we all kind of banded together
and
we we essentially moved from that bad
environment to create our own
environment and part of
that involved uh the
occult I see so would you say that there
was a particular thing that you guys
shared in common that Drew you to the
occult and if so what would that be yeah
there were several things one of which
was music and at that time it was uh
Hard Rock heavy metal music it it it
spoke to where we were it um played Into
The Angst that we felt about we don't
belong here what are we doing here uh
there was a lot of anger to it and not
just anger but also it gave you kind of
a feeling of power I see so would you
say when you say heavy m music heavy
metal music for the people in our
audience that don't know what what
exactly that is could you describe that
medium yeah it it um is essentially if
you think of just your regular rock
music yeah think of it as that but
louder more distorted angrier with
instead of singing often times shouting
the themes are much darker and often
revolve around anger uh violence uh and
the occults many times and uh uh you
know some of the bands that we were into
even the names suggested that like for
instance Black Sabbath Iron Maiden which
is a torture device and these kinds of
bands like that they're overtly
Blasphemous I mean a Black Sabbath you
know exactly and someone who's not
familiar with what the Sabbath mean May
Overlook that and then begin to have
some you know second thoughts about who
they subscribe to in terms of their
faith and their belief so you found this
to be true for you and your friends and
where did that take you did that open up
other gateways for you was was were
there messages in the music that took
you to other places for sure it was a
very Blasphemous message as you said so
it was definitely
anti-god and some were even more toward
the occult and even Satanism some of
them okay we tended to shy away from the
very very dark stuff but um but even so
even the lighter heavy metal was still
pretty bad and it wasn't just the music
so although that was definitely a
contributing factor um it was a whole
constellation of things together uh we
started to get into role playing games
like Dungeons and Dragons which have a
lot of occultic themes in them indeed um
we got into a lot of fantasy literature
which is very similar in that way right
um and all of that together really gave
us a an appetite for it and then all
that was left was to have something come
to satisfy that appetite in a more overt
manner so how did you actually satisfy
this occult need this thirst did you did
did this take you from music into
actually practicing and and if so what
were the the tools and the mechanisms
that you use to explore that spiritual
realm yeah um one of my friends one day
came to me and said hey I got this book
it's pretty amazing and he was also uh
like me a you know Jewish kid who's
getting into all of this stuff yes and
he said this this book that talks about
a combination of the occult and Judaism
and it does it through this thing called
cabala which I never heard of but
supposedly it was this mystical branch
of
Judaism that um kind of fills in a gap
there that supposedly is missing and uh
it acted as a Gateway because so is this
the same relig that I see many of like
the Hollywood celebrities they'll have
like a little red uh string tied around
their wrist yeah and it's for a while it
was very popular I think even Madonna
was into it for a while right um it it
it is
a it's appealing because it still allows
you to have your ties back to the mother
faith I see but it still allows you to
essentially practice the occult car
launch and and that's what it did for us
it it introduced us into the world of
the occult they they called it cabala or
another word for it they use was magic
but spelled with a k k right and the K
is intentional I learned that it it
differentiates like stage Magic from the
occult magic exactly now as you're
practicing this did you find that there
were let's say explore positive things
that you gained from actually practicing
this yeah absolutely because it
incorporates uh things like uh
meditation like Transcendental
Meditation which um it does have some
benefits right it does uh allows you to
focus to some degree um it also and I
don't know if this was just
psychological but it gave me a lot of
confidence where I could you know I
could talk to anybody associate with
anybody and feel comfortable with them
and people noticed it and they said hey
o you're different something's different
about you but in a good way and of
course that fed my
pride right I I could share in that
because in in my days as a yoga
practitioner and and instructor I found
that the meditation was very peaceful
you know you get your heart rate down
you seem to just have a clear mind and
you do don't really realize that that
kind of that status of being
disconnected even from yourself allows
entities in and you're deceived and you
don't quite know just yet that you're
creeping into a place that there's
potentially no return for exactly did
you experience negative impacts from
having done so for sure um the first of
which
was I I was a physics major in college
and uh part of the way I was able to pay
for my tuition was to work uh as a
research assistant uh and so I depended
on that money and what would start to
happen is I would start to hear uh this
is this is very strange but you've heard
cicas right yeah absolutely they're here
aren't they they're very loud yeah and I
would hear them just in my head and just
when I was about to work it would start
and over that as like a frequency above
it was a voice it wasn't quite a human
voice and I couldn't make out what it
was saying but I could make out the
emotion and intent of the voice and what
I made out was anger hatred and a deep
satisfaction in seeing me suffer
incredible and it was like nothing I had
ever experienced before it freaked me
out the first time it happened and it
continued to
happen every few days it would just come
back and it would go away in a few
minutes come back a few
days I finally went to one of my friends
who was also into the same thing I was
and I asked him hey you know I'm
experiencing this weird stuff have you
ever had anything like this he said he
laughed he he said oh yeah happens to me
sometimes you just need to do the right
rituals to protect yourself against
those evil spirits and it was that was
this the first time that you heard it
referred to as such yes as evil spirits
because up until that point it wasn't
evil spirits it was Angels ah angels and
I thought what in the world of course
evil spirits are angels I didn't know
that Fallen Angels know two different
classes at that time and when he told me
that it was it was just like this punch
in the head that I realized whoa what am
I messing with here so now there's a
demarcation between ignorance and now
informed consent M did you find that
even now that the light bulb had clicked
on that you were able to thwart the
efforts of this entity possessing you or
was it just doing what is what it was
going to do so what I did did is I
dialed back all the stuff I was into
into just what I call the light stuff
yoga light Stu meditation but not any of
the rituals and it actually did help to
some degree it happened less often it
still happened from time to
time but um but other things happened in
its place and actually the one that
really sealed the coffin for me of the
occult was when I had worked at a new
age book Bookshop I actually worked at a
new age book shop at one point toward
the end did you seek this job job out or
okay I did yeah yeah so even though you
were having you know second thoughts
about it and you were now devising a
plan to limit this this interaction with
dark Spirits you still sought more
information isn't that crazy W that is
quite ironic yeah that speaks to the
pull and the power of this yes right yes
yes I didn't want to let go of it I just
wanted to get rid of the bad effects I
see and so I worked at this new new age
bookstore and my boss she would have
these they're not really seances but
they're kind of like um channeling
sessions where um she would play this
tape of this person who would Channel an
alien entity as they called it and this
alien entity was supposed to talk about
the secrets of the universe and while we
were listening to that we would also
meditate so that we could focus better
interesting and I did that a few times
and then I noticed I would get these
weird fits of anger just they would just
well up within me and one time my um I
had been talking to my dad on the phone
we got into an argument about something
I don't even remember what now but um I
started to just light into him I was
just so angry and
I blanked out and the next thing I know
when I came to the phone was was uh I
had hung up the phone and then it rang
and my mom called me and said what did
you just say to your dad I've never seen
him this upset
before and I couldn't tell her because I
didn't know I don't even I don't
remember what I told experience right I
thought oh my goodness what am I doing
right what have I done here yeah exactly
you know one of the reasons I wanted to
go into the the cult was I wanted to
become an enlightened being right that's
one of the promises it gives you it does
and this was turning me into a monster
and the the word Enlightenment you know
you find that word across the board in
all the the religions and the thing
that's really interesting about it is of
course we have curiosity and we have
this innate desire and this this whole
this emptiness that we need filled and
the the counterfeits are out there and
you dabble in these things and the hole
actually gets bigger and more gaping and
you just keep trying to fill it and it
becomes voluminous and so how did you
find your way like what s satiated your
your willingness you know to to to
continue in this path what actually
ended it for you and and got you to get
out well I would say that that
experience ended it for me um you know I
I stopped working at that store and I at
that point I didn't know what to believe
but I knew I couldn't mess with that
anymore because it was it was messing me
up right and I didn't know what I was
looking for I I had graduated at that
point and I was trying to figure out
what to do with my life and I decided
okay I'm going to go into neurobiology
because I want to understand the
brain I was still looking for something
to fill that void right and what
happened was at that point I had met my
wife to be and she was a new student in
that same program that I was just
starting and I discovered that she was a
Christian which I wasn't a fan of
Christians uh coming from a Jewish
background right from a Jewish
background and from a new age background
y yep um but she just intrigued me she
was so different in a good way uh of
course physically attractive but also
her her spirit her character was
attractive and I'd never met anyone like
her before I I didn't even know how to
pronounce the den nomination she
belonged to seventh day something or
other right right and it didn't make a
whole lot of sense to me at first I was
like wait Christians who keep the
Sabbath how is that a thing I thought
only Jews kept the Sabbath and
Christians go to church on Sunday she
was patient with me she explained things
to me but um I started to read some of
the books in her
library and you know I read some of the
books from CS Lewis who really helped me
understand the philosophical basis for
Christianity I I started to read the
Bible which uh up until that point I had
never really done um people would read
the Bible to me this was an uncanny
thing every few months somebody on the
subway even homeless people would just
single me out to read passages of the
Bible to me I never understood that the
Holy Spirit yeah exactly it was the Holy
Spirit planting little seeds and now
they were starting to germinate amen and
I started to read the gospels and I saw
this Jesus not as just this enlightened
Guru but actually as the Son of God um
what really stood in my way at that
point wasn't so much the desire to be a
Christian I really actually was drawn to
it it was you know I was a scientist and
I wanted to have a concrete basis for my
faith and I felt like I needed to know
that the Bible was real and that Jesus
was the Messiah I needed something
verifiable and God actually answered
that prayer he um he orchestrated such
that my wife and I were getting serious
at this point and we were going to go
out to meet her parents they they
happened to live out in Baran Springs in
Michigan and her stepdad was a pastor at
that point there and he taught a yearly
class on uh this was Christmas time so
you know the Advent of the the first
Advent of the Messiah right and uh he
talked about Daniel 9 and how the Bible
predicted that advent and he went
through it in detail and showed all the
dates and he said look if you want to
you can go verify the dates go get an
encyclopedia go there were there was no
internet really to so to to speak of at
that point so I did I actually went and
verified it and the dates lined up to
the year to the year to the year it was
amazing and uh and this is concrete yes
evidence that you were searching for yes
and you had already experience growing
up reading the Torah right these these
books are also included in the Christian
Bible yes and at no point were any of
your philosophical or theological
teachers pointing to any of these facts
no definitely not in fact I had heard of
The Book of Daniel only from Daniel and
the Lion's Den you know was a kid story
we were taught but no other part of the
book was ever taught to us and in fact I
found out only later that um you're not
supposed to read the prophetic writings
of Daniel it's forbidden in Rabbi
Judaism and you wonder
why so it um it was definitely a turning
point because it gave me
the the rational basis for my faith that
I was looking for and at that point it
was just a matter of okay now what I
need courage because you know you could
be convicted of something and convinced
in your mind but now you have to face
your friends your family all of whom
will not be happy so now you have this
woman in your life who's helping you
walk in A New Path now you have a book
that's giving you and filling you um how
did that then turn your your social
environment did it wreck havoc did it
encourage others did you see a
difference I did see a difference um it
it it replaced a lot of the things in my
life with better things I see so I had
friends who then were no longer friends
because they thought I was crazy crazy
and that I had joined a cult yeah that's
very Comm which is ironic yes given they
were into the a cult and they thought I
was joining a cult um my parents didn't
understand it and were very hurt by
it but you know over time uh I have
better friends yes a church family and
my own family and um my parents have
since softened their stance on it they
even occasionally when they visit come
to church with me and uh so I would say
that uh I consider all of my former life
loss amen so that I may have Christ
praise God so what I'm hearing is that
it was worth the sacrifice it was worth
giving up and did you feel the
love you know moving on your spirit was
there any uh remnants of that anger that
was welling up inside of you did you
feel any of that no no it all went away
uh it was like Jesus bound all of those
things so that they could no longer
torment me yes
and I I have to thank him every day for
that he's good I I shudder to think what
would have happened had those
circumstances that he orchestrated not
happened what would I
become so I I thank him every day and
I've come to know him better each day
and uh nothing
can top that so the friends that you
lost have you ever tried to witness to
them yeah yeah I I have it it it it
didn't work out it didn't it didn't work
out now why do you think that it worked
for you but it didn't work for them so I
would say part of that is actually if I
were honest on me because uh you know
God is very patient with each of us he
knows where where we are he knows how to
reach us and he doesn't push us too hard
true he doesn't he doesn't throw
everything at us all at once and
unfortunately people aren't like God and
I certainly wasn't uh I discovered this
new truth and I thought I'm going to
save my friends and I just came at them
with you know both guns blazing Bible
thumping yes hear the proof text here
all the things you should and shouldn't
do and and they were like you're nuts
and you know now I I've learned to tone
it down Jesus's method is to get to know
people first mingle with people right
get on their level yes right see them
for where they are and and show them
that you care about them as a person
first not just as a you know a feather
in your cap and
and um doing that really has made a
difference it takes a lot longer but
it's better but it's worth it yes so ol
in our last thoughts here is there a
method that you would give to to
Watchers or viewers that were in your
same place that have friends that are in
the occult how would you say to them to
plant seeds moving forward I I would say
number one be a Christian just be a
Christian in other words they
may and I was on the giving end of this
at one point they may mock you for what
you
believe they may you know sneer at you
don't stoop to their level right be a
Christian yes Jesus said turn the other
cheek do do that it it it does have an
effect it may not be noticeable to you
because they want to hold on to their
pride but it will have that effect and
then the other thing is be available to
them when they need help when they need
help be there for them because they will
need help amen this is a destructive
lifestyle it it corrodes the spirit and
the body and it's only a matter of time
before they will start to have
in problems in their life and you need
to be there for them to help them pick
up the pieces and show them a better way
thank you so much brother ol for being
with us today and sharing your testimony
it's so encouraging to see how you plant
seeds remember we're not responsible for
saving lives only planting seeds and
being C- laborers with Christ in the
words of the Apostle Paul I planted
Apollo watered but God gave the increase
so then neither he who plants is
anything nor he who Waters but God who
gives the increase be gentle and like my
brother oik faithful and intentional in
your collaboration efforts with Christ
he insures by so doing that the fields
will indeed be right for Harvest please
join us next time this has been a wolf
in sheep's
clothing
[Music]
[Applause]